un quartier où en est la manifestation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez elle progresse vers matignon
nous sommes très près des invalides dans
la fameuse avenue de ségur
plus de 2000 personnes ont fait ce
déplacement en jeu cette prime de 183
euros qui n'est réservé qu'à une
catégorie de personnels principalement
les hospitaliers et donc tout le monde
ne la touche pas dans les allées du
secteur sanitaire médico social et
social par exemple les salariés du du
privé ne l'ont pas non plus alors ce
sont les oubliés du ségur 1 il y a les
bleus personnel technique administratif
et également les aides à domicile
alors je suis là précisément avec
anthony à cadres chefs de file et faux
dans le groupe e vivent à voulpaix
privée qui regroupe plusieurs dizaines
d'établissements
bonjour horde des cadereaux alors quelle
est la situation en ce moment que
demandez vous alors on demande
aujourd'hui que les oubliés de ségur
obtiennent les 183 euros
on est tous venus ici pour les 183 euros
pour tous je vous donne par exemple dans
mon établissement dans mon groupe que
vivent où il ya quarante-cinq mille
salariés aussi bien du secteur
assurantiel que du secteur libre 3
c'est-à-dire des sam des soins à
domicile des ehpad aujourd'hui des
salariés qui font le même métier dans
des soins infirmiers à domicile n'ont
pas les 183 euros
les salariés qui font le métier
d'aide-soignant d'infirmiers d'agents
d'agents besoin dans les ehpad ou obtenu
ses 183 euros
ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui c'est que
tous les salariés obtiennent est pas en
2022 aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui
qu'ils nous les fonds avaient très vite
ça bloque à à quel niveau parce que
certains ehpad par exemple du privé ont
accordé 7
cette augmentation qui n'est pas
d'ailleurs pérenne mais pourquoi tout le
monde
alors c'est une décision gouvernementale
que je ne comprends pas aujourd'hui je
ne comprends pas pourquoi un si petit
nombre n'ont pas obtenu ses 183 euros
c'est bien le gouvernement qui ne veut
pas les donner alors il paraîtrait qu'il
y aurait des avancées une décision
unilatérale du gouvernement qui
accorderait les de ségur mais à partir
de janvier 2022 est ce qu'on a demandé à
ses salariés de rester à la maison
lorsqu'il y avait la pandémie est ce qu
on leur a demandé d'aller sur le terrain
pourquoi on leur donne tort aujourd'hui
les 183 euros sur la question la
pérennité
en effet cette prime n'est pas pérenne
elle est l'état un même pas calculé le
bon temps il manquerait 6% du fait des
réductions fillon le vivent aujourd'hui
ses salariés dans les établissements
sans salariés qui sont les oubliés de
ségur et le vivent très mal
ils sont insatisfaits ils sont je vais
rire de vous ils sont dégoûtés dégoûtés
de cette situation et ils sont venus au
c'ur aujourd'hui le dire aujourd'hui
pourquoi nous on n'obtient pas ses 183
euros
pourquoi il ya une différence de
traitement entre ma collègue qui
travaille en ehpad et moi qui travaille
en siad par exemple 5 me soit lapin ado
miss et et et aujourd'hui ils ressentent
ça comme une injustice une injustice
c'est le point départ aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est le 8 avril c'est le
point de départ de la contestation et et
ce à la population le comprend j'imagine
que le comprends très bien
si vous faites le même métier pourquoi
vous êtes payés différemment vous
remercie anthony cadre pour ces
explications donc en direct de la main
fait station qui se dirige vers matignon
pour obtenir un arrêt des disparités
entre les différents personnels du
sanitaire médico social et social
merci katia technique en direct donc du
cortège parisien et